so x squared plus 1 what does it tell
you about the intercepts it's a cubic
so you'd usually expect it to have like
you know three times like that but as
you know cubics don't have to have three
they can answer you and they can have
one they kind of zero I hope you can see
why that is but anyway
there's just one where the origin okay
comes from this of this part of the
product that factor right x squared plus
1/3 that's a bit interesting as one of
the factors it tells something useful
namely that x squared plus 1 right is
never equal to 0 never ever ever ever so
therefore I'm not gonna get any
intercepts from this part okay so x
equals 0 that's my early intercept and
it just so happens when you pop that
back in you get the origin so one
intercept if you were to plot some
points you would get this kind of shape
tada
okay here's the graph we're gonna wants
to imply this morning right oh there you
go
now what can we to use to describe this
graph ok well we actually already have a
lot of language to talk about it think
about its gradient ok it's always going
from bottom to top so how could we
describe this function
yeah it's increasing and it's it's
monotonically increasing because it's up
it's always going up it never turns
around there are no stationary points
and it's never it never stops
right so it's always increasing okay
let's go a little further and dig into
this though because it's not always
increasing in the same way ok so what I
wants to think about is well gradient we
get the information of the gradient from
the derivative right so let's work out
that derivative okay look at your first
line X cubed plus 1 so my derivative
will be good
simple stuff okay now you can see
therefore why I have no stationary
points on this graph because three x
squared plus one I'm actually going to
graph that on if you've got another
color on hand you might like to do the
same as well what would this look like
in relation to this graph well it's got
an X into start a y-intercept of 1 and
then the rest of it just sort of goes
off like son
okay so kawaii and I've got dy/dx in the
same breath okay so you can see because
do you wanna DX my green Lions navigate
see your antivirus there station points
okay but you can also say that this is
not constant line right the gradient
does change okay and in fact how can we
describe its change let's think about
this you can you can say it's up its
gradient is parabolic what does that
mean for the original breath well what I
want you to do is alright our staff
focused on the left hand side the
graphic so I'm gonna cut this whole one
I know he'll look at it okay we got that
me probably yeah probably I probably
removing part of the graph as I speak
but anyway have a look at that it's
increasing it is still monotonically
increasing but how would you describe I
mean it's not increasing the same Pia as
it is here now let me say that again in
fact I might even join it down for which
I'm gonna the NCI ruined it a little bit
let's let's put this down because it's
actually an important phrase it's not
the only way to describe it but it's
it's a good one um what smooth line is
destroyed okay so gonna be here right
and in fact you might even like to write
down 4x is less than zero okay the graph
or I could take Y write Y of X because
it's a function that is increasing at a
decreasing rate so you can see if I went
through the left most part of the graph
that is where the graph is steepest okay
see here right and it gets shallower and
Challenger doesn't stop there no
stationary points okay but it's um it's
increased rate is slowing down okay
increasing how to decrease right now
what does that correspond to you have a
look at the green graph right the green
graph tells you how much the blue graph
is changing okay
so you can see it's increasing it's
always increasing because the green
graph is always positive positive the
sign of the first derivative is positive
that's why it's always increasing but as
the derivative gets slower lower lower
that corresponds to the fact that this
graph is slowing down okay so if you
like if this was like our Apple right
the Apple is going up but it's getting
slower as it goes this so if you
actually were to record the speed of the
Apple as it goes talk okay that speed is
reducing okay sort of which is what it
was doing
you know the pull of gravity was making
it sort of just slowed down okay so
first is lesson zero it's increasing in
a DCCC rate but if you go past the
origin values right it's increasing at
an increasing rate because you can see
it's getting steeper and steeper and
steeper so if you like if you thought of
it like as a car right it's driving
along at a certain speed but then you're
you're pushing the panel down it's
getting faster and faster and faster and
faster forever which are gonna come nice
and calm so i increasing at a decreasing
rate and increasing at an increasing
rate now do you see what's going on to
you play in this first part increasing
increasing are talking about the first
derivative right but then I'm also
talking about how the first derivative
is changing how the first derivative
dy/dx is changing now how much something
changes right that's the whole idea of
what a driven it is right the first
derivative tells you the green line
tells you how much the blue line is
changing okay so